what's up everyone Eber here with
hardware connects and here we are with
another one of these graphic card
reviews and interestingly enough we're
actually taking a look at invidious
affordable GPU of their r-tx series so
this is the RT X 2070 and before again
to the test results and all that kind of
stuff
I just want to describe this situation
or this recording scenario because this
is not the typical hardware connect
studio space in fact I'm actually
recording this from a hotel in Beijing
so yeah this might be this video might
be a little bit shorter than normally
what you're expecting but needless to
say all the testing has been completed
before we left ok so a few weeks ago you
guys may recall that we didn't explain
video talking about the RT X 2070 its
architecture and what India is offering
for its ridiculous
$600 founders Edition price tag so if
you're interested in learning more about
the core clocks the specs and all that
kind of stuff
I'd highly recommend checking out that
video right over here but it actually
turns out that a lot of predictions from
then have been proven to be right but
some weren't this launch is also a bit
odd since there were some weird stuff
going on behind the scenes so more on
that right after message from our
sponsor so you're saying this is the
most colorful way to cool I'm telling
you the master liquid ml 360 are RGB is
the way to go cooler masters new 360
millimetre all-in-one liquid cooler is
all about performance in style with a
custom low resistance radiator and dual
chamber pump wood sleeve tubing for that
premium look while being totally
flexible the fan strike your balance for
air pressure and airflow with
transparent blades to perfectly match
the colorful combination of the pump
then you can sync via its own controller
or through various addressable and
12-volt RGB connectors all right perhaps
you should check it out in the scripture
middle alright so I think it's time for
some honest talk guys because nothing
about the r-tx 2017 launch has been
typical and everyone here is pretty
frustrated about a week ago we still had
no info on samples or even in
communication within video remember this
was just a few business days prior to a
major launch and so we decided to do a
little bit of investigating well it
turns out that after being called out
about starting at prices that never
materialized for the r-tx 20 atti and
the Arctic's 2080 things were going to
be done a bit differently this time
instead of sending out founders editions
for the review in p had told their board
partners to sample their 5
million-dollar r-tx 27 TS i'm
gently a very few of them were producing
those in time for launch so they had to
scramble to shift with their production
we also heard that partners we're told
that they couldn't send out a pre
overclock card without also sending a
$500 sample but that requirement was
dropped at the last minute Nvidia is
obviously trying to control the
messaging on this launch and refocus our
attention towards their entry-level r-tx
2070 instead of the ultra expensive $600
founders Edition I'm perfectly fine with
that provided it gives us a realistic
snapshot of the market and you know what
I don't think that's what will happen
after talking to every board partner it
seems like the majority of carts will be
hitting the $550 to $600 price points
it's obvious things didn't work out like
Nvidia plan since most board partners
we're very late with sampling but no one
here is gonna complain about having
about two days to put this review
together because you know what we'll do
whatever it takes to get you guys the
info you need without crying about
losing sleep or long hours that includes
filming this video on the other side of
the world okay so let's get to the GPUs
that I'm gonna be covering first up is
the asus r-tx 27 t turbo which is a
pretty basic blower style card like I'm
sure you can predict it'll hit the
magical five million dollar price point
expected to be in fairly limited supply
at launch with availability at Newegg
and a bit later at Amazon and other
retailers there isn't any overclock and
boost frequencies is rated at sixteen
ten megahertz the interesting thing here
is that it uses a six plus eight pin
layout even though TDP is rated at 175
watts it actually looks like a sickly
took there are TX 2080 turbo PCB and
popped in an RTX 2015 - in the other
card is much more interesting in my
opinion this is the EVGA r-tx 28 exc and
it's priced at five hundred and fifty
dollars despite having a custom cooler
and an overclocked boost frequency of a
1710 megahertz this happens to be the
same spec as the invidious founders
Edition which costs a good fifty dollars
more the XE is a bit long at ten point
six inches but nothing like some of the
alternatives like a Sousa Strix OC or
MSI's duke series EVGA also happens to
have a longer more comprehensive
warranty than nvidia and this card
should be widely available right at
launch we're also going to approach
comparisons a bit differently in this
video and focus on the cards that are
of the overall market right now the
problem is that buyers have less and
less choice when it comes to
alternatives to the r-tx 2070 unless
they go into the used market the gtx
1080 and gtx 1070 TI are in short supply
all around but the gtx 1070 is a bit
better but they're still going up in
price so here's a quick list of the
cards that I'm gonna be using here along
with their current approximate prices
unfortunately some of these have been
increasing lately because of low supply
versus high demand so be aware of that
I'll leave a link in the description to
the lowest priced and in stock GTX 10
series cards I could find but these were
the ones we either had on hand or
purchased in the last few weeks alright
so with all that out of the way let's
jump right into the benchmarks starting
first with how well the EVGA and Asus
r-tx 27t cards can maintain their clock
speeds I was a bit worried that the
blower stock card from Asus would had
some higher temperatures but that didn't
really happen the max it achieved was 73
degrees Celsius but the EVGA xcs dual
fan downdraft cooler ended up easily
beating it with its peak temp of 68
degree Celsius you can also see that in
order to maintain these 73 degrees
Celsius mark the Asus turbo had to
fluctuate its clock speeds quite a bit
and it ended up running around 1680
megahertz which is right in line with
his specs EVGA on the other hand is
really stable after it settles around
1810 megahertz but how does this all
translate into performance and games
well let's roll the benchmarks you're
more than welcome to pause on any of
them if you want to take a closer look
at them just keep in mind that in order
to reduce CPU bottlenecks running all
these tests on an i9 7900 X overclocked
to 4.7 4 gigahertz with 32 gigabytes of
memory overclocked to 3600 megahertz
[Music]
so there you have an idea of where these
two cards stack up to the competition
but there are some other things that we
need to look into first let's talk about
power consumption first since the r-tx
cards have absolutely huge cores and do
tend to require a lot of juice so it
turns out that power consumption isn't
all that bad for either of these cards
right now with both needing less than an
overclocked GTX 1080
but what we don't know is what will
happen to these numbers when r-tx
features are enabled remember a lot of
the die space is taken up by the RT
intensive course and normal applications
those aren't being used okay now on to
sound testing I was a bit worried that
the Asus RT X 2070 turbo would be quite
loud but it actually wasn't it's a bit
louder than the downdraft coolers but
you are also getting the advantage of
exhausting hot air outside the case that
could be a real benefit if you are using
a smaller form factor system and for the
eb g XC well what can we say it's very
very quiet
well the benchmarks certainly provide an
interesting insight into the RT x 27 TS
plays in the market however actually
buying a GPU right now isn't an easy
process at all and that's because the
existing 10 series GTX 10 series cards
are getting harder and harder to find
and you know prices are kind of all over
the place I mean if you look hard enough
you may be able to find a GTX 1084 470
dollars or 10 semi TI for $400 but for
the most part they are either a little
bit more expensive than that price point
or there are out of stock now you could
look the used market is certainly an
option to look into but they are flooded
with mining GPUs so watch out for those
anyways coming back to the RT x 2070 and
you know I've talked about the whole
mess surrounding this launch so I'm not
going to touch on that again but is very
clear that the $600 RTX 2070 founder's
Edition is a ridiculously overpriced GPU
period luckily we were able to benchmark
the two other cards so the Asus RT X
2070 ended up going back and forth with
the EVGA GTX 10 ATSC 2 in the tests but
ended up just ahead at both 1440p and 4k
remember this is a reference RT X 2017
versus an overclocked card but at the
same time the prices are about the same
at $500 the real question is whether or
not the turbo or any other $500 RT x
2070 card will be widely
at lunch I have a feeling that they
won't be based on our talks with bore
partners now with the EVGA r-tx 2070 XE
is a bit more interesting since for 10%
more than the asus card you're getting
four to six percent better performance
improved cooling results and quieter
operation but being interesting doesn't
make it a good value it's just less
expensive than the overpriced r-tx 2070
founders Edition are takes 2080 and the
RT x 20 80 TI even with the Arctic's
2070 that's available right now I think
people should still wait and see how the
market fares in to 2019 before jumping
into RT X because prices are actually a
little bit or quite a bit higher than
what the 1070 and the GTX 1070 TI used
to be at at launch and you know the RT x
features that you're paying for right
now aren't necessarily available at this
at the time of making this video so it's
really pointless to jump into a platform
that offers or that has features that
just can't be taken advantage of
meanwhile the performance of these cards
aren't drastically or they're not a
significant improvement over what the
GTX sent 70 series cards used to offer
for about a year or so and I think
that's a problem guys so there you guys
have it while the RT X 2070 is finally
here it's really hard to get excited
about a GPU that costs $500 I'm a bar
with hundred connects thank you so much
watching let me know what you guys think
about this GPU in the comments down
below subscribe to a new boot sequence
channel right over here before lilius
tech news and rumors you can also check
out some relevant content over here as
well I'm signing off and I'll see you
guys in the next one